Michael Levin's work on regulating
intractable pattern formation in living
systems has made him one of the most
compelling biologists of our time in
Translation this means that his team is
sussing out how to develop limbs
regenerate limbs how to generate minds
and even life extension by manipulating
electric signals rather than genetics or
epigenetics his work is something that I
consider to be worthy of a Nobel Prize
and I don't think I've said that about
anyone on the podcast Michael Levin's
previous podcast on toe is in the
description that's a solo episode with
him where we go into a two-hour Deep
dive as well as there's a Theo locution
so that is him and another guest just
like today except between Carl friston
and Chris fields on Consciousness
yoshibak is widely considered to be the
Pinnacle of an AI researcher dealing
with emotion modeling and multi-agent
systems a large focus of boxes to build
a model of the Mind from strong AI
speaking of Mind Bach is one of the most
inventive Minds in the field of computer
science and has appeared several times
on toll prior again there's a solo
episode there's also a theologution
between yoshibak and Donald Hoffman on
Consciousness and yo shabach and John
vervaki also on in reality biology has
much to teach us about artificial
intelligence and vice versa this
discussion between two brilliant
researchers is something that I'm
extremely
lucky blessed fortunate to be a part of
as well as us as collective as an
audience that are fortunate enough to
witness approximately 30 minutes into
the conversation you'll see two sponsors
they are Masterworks and Roman I implore
you not to skip it as firstly watching
it supports toe directly and then
secondly they're fascinating companies
in and of themselves additionally you'll
hear from one more Trade coffee around
the one and a half hour mark thank you
and enjoy this theolocution between
yoshabak and Michael Levin welcome both
Professor Michael Evan and yoshabak it's
an honor to have you on the toll podcast
again both of you and then together
right now thank you it's great to be
here
likewise I enjoy very much being here
and look forward to this conversation I
look forward to it as well so we'll
start off with the question of what is
it that you Michael find most
interesting about yosho's work and then
Yoshi will go for you toward Michael
yeah
um I really enjoy the uh the breadth so
so I've been looking I think I've
probably read almost everything on your
on your website you know the short kind
of blog pieces and everything and uh
yeah I'm I'm uh I'm I'm a big fan of of
the breadth of of tackling a lot of the
different issues that you do with
respect to uh you know computation and
and cognition and Ai and uh you know and
ethics and everything I I really like
that aspect of it so
then you're sure yeah my apologies my
blog is not up to date I haven't uh
done any updates for a few years now on
it I think
um so of course I'm still in the Pro
process of progressing and having new
ideas and the ideas that I had in recent
years I have a great overlap with a lot
of the things that you are working on
and when I listen to your Lex podcast
last night there were many thoughts that
you had that I had stumbled on
um
uh that I've never heard from anybody
else and so I found this very
fascinating and thought
um maybe let's look at some of these
thoughts first and then go from there
and expand
um Beyond those ideas but uh I for
instance found after thinking about how
cells work
kind of obvious but missed by most
people in Neuroscience or in science in
general is that every cell has the
ability to send multiple message types
and receive multiple message types and
do this conditionally and learn an
average conditions to do that and to
modulate this also every cell is an
individual reinforcement learning agent
single-sided animal that tries to
survive by cooperating with its
environment gets most of its rewards
from its environment
and as a result this means that every
cell can in principle function like a
neuron it can fulfill the same learning
and information processing tasks as a
new one the only difference that exists
with respect to neurons or the main
difference is that they cannot do this
over very long distances because they
are mostly connected only to the cells
that are directly adjacent of course new
ones also only communicate to adjacent
cells but the adjacency of neurons is
such that they have Excellence parts of
the cell that reach very far through the
organism so in some sense in your one is
a telegraph cell that uses very specific
messages that are encoded in a way like
Morsi signals in extremely short high
energy bursts that allow to send
messages over the very long distances
very quickly to move the muscles of an
animal at the limit of what physics
allows
so it can compete with other animals and
search for food and in order to make
that happen it also needs to have a
model of the world that gets updated at
this higher rate so there is going to be
an information processing system that is
duplicating basically this cellular
brain that is made from all the other
cells in the body of the organism and at
some point these two systems get
decoupled they have their own codes
their own language so to speak and but
it still makes sense I guess to see the
brain as a telegraphic extension of the
community of cells in the body and for
me this Insight that I stumbled on just
because means and motive that Evolution
would equip cells with doing that
information processing if the organism
is long enough lives long enough and if
the cells share common genetic Destiny
so they can get attuned to each other in
an organism that basically every
organism has the potential to become
intelligent and if it gets old enough to
process enough data to get to a very
high degree of understanding of its
environment in principle so of course a
normal houseplant is not going to get
very old with compared to us because the
information processing is so much slower
so they're not going to be very smart
but at the level of ecosystems it's
conceivable that there is quite
considerable intelligence and then I
stumbled on this notion that our
ancestors thought that one day in
Fairyland equals seven years in human
land which is taught in the Artemis and
also I just at some point I revised my
notion of what the spirit is for
instance is a spirit is it's an old bird
for the operating system for an
autonomous robot
and the event this word was invented the
um only autonomous robots that were
known were people and plants and animals
and nation states and ecosystems
right whatever no robots built by people
yet but uh there was this pattern of
control in it that people could observe
that was not directly tied to the
hardware that was realized by the
hardware but disembodied in a way and
this notion of several is something that
we lost after the enlightenment when we
tried to deal with the
um wrong Christian metaphysics and
Superstition that came with it and threw
out a lot of babies with the bath water
and suddenly we basically lost a lot of
Concepts especially this concept of
software that existed before in a way
this a software being a control pattern
or a pattern of course a structure that
exists at a certain level of course
graining as some type of very very
specific physical law that he exists by
looking at reality from a certain angle
and what I liked about your work is that
you systematically have focused on this
direction of what their can do that a
cell is an agent and that levels of
agency emerge in the interaction between
cells and and you use a very clear
language and uh clear Concepts and you
obviously are driven by questions that
you want to answer which is unusual in
science I found that most of our
contemporaries in science get broken it
if it doesn't happen earlier during the
PHD into people who apply methods in
teams instead of people who join
Academia because they think it's the
most valuable thing they can do with
their lives to pursue questions that
they are interested and want to make
progress on
all right Michael there's plenty to
respond to yeah yeah lots of lots of
ideas
um yeah I think I think it's very uh
your point is very interesting about you
know what what it really what really
fundamentally is the difference between
neurons and other cells of course
evolutionarily they're reusing Machinery
that has been around for a very long
time since the time of bacteria
basically right so our multi our
unicellular ancestors had a lot of the
same machinery and and even I mean of
course axons are very can be very long
but but uh there are sort of
intermediate structures right there are
tunneling nanotubes and things that
allow cells to connect to maybe five or
ten diameter cell diameters away right
so so not terribly long but but also not
immediate neighbors necessarily so that
kind of architecture has been around for
a while and people like roll so well
look at
um
but a very brain-like electrical
signaling in bacterial Colony so this is
you know I think I think Evolution began
to reuse this toolkit specifically of
using this kind of communication to
scale up
um with the computational and other
kinds of um other kinds of uh tricks uh
yeah a really long time ago you know and
I like to I like to imagine that if
somebody had come to the people who were
inventing connectionism and the first
you know sort of perceptrons and neural
networks and so on if somebody had come
to them and said oh by the way sorry you
know we're with the biologists we we got
it wrong it's not the thinking isn't in
the brain it's in the liver and so then
the question is what would they do right
what would they have changed anything
about what they're doing and we said ah
now we have to rethink our model or with
is that fine who cares uh this is
exactly the same the same model
everything works just as well so I often
I often think about that that that
question what exactly do we mean by by
neurons and isn't it interesting that we
are able to to steal most of the tools
the concepts the Frameworks the the math
from neuroscience and apply it to
problems in other spaces so not movement
in three-dimensional space with muscles
but for example movement through
amorphous space right anatomical
amorphous space the techniques can't
tell the difference we use all the same
stuff optogenetics neurotransmitter
signaling we model active inference and
uh we see perceptual by stability you
name it you know we take Concepts from
from neuroscience and we apply it out
elsewhere in the body and uh generally
speaking uh everything works exactly the
same and that shows this I think what
you were saying that there's this really
interesting uh kind of um symmetry
between these these uh that that a lot
of the distinctions that we've been
making are you know in terms of having
different departments and different PHD
programs and other things that say you
know this is neuroscience this is
developmental biology a lot of these
things are just not um uh not as not as
firm distinctions as we used to think
yeah I suspect that people who insist on
strong disciplinary boundaries do this
out of of a protective impulse and what
I noticed by I was studying many
disciplines when I was young that
um the different methodologies are so
incompatible across fields that when I
was studying philosophy
um by or psychology I felt that computer
scientists would be laughing about the
methods that each of these fields are
using to justify what they're doing and
this I think is indicative of a defect
because if you take science into the
current regime of regulating it entirely
by peer review there is no external
Authority even the grand authorities are
mostly fields or people who have been
trained in The Sciences in existing
paradigms and then are finding the
continuation of those paradigms from the
outside
this um
meta paradigmatic thinking it does not
really exist that much in a
peer-reviewed paradigm and ultimately
when you do peer review for a couple
Generations it also means that if your
peers deteriorate there is nothing who
pulls your science back
and uh what I missed specifically in a
lot of the way which Neuroscience is
done is what you call the engineering
stance
and this engineering sense is very
powerful and you get it automatically
when you're a computer scientist because
you don't really care about language is
it written in what you care in is what
causal pattern is realized and how can
this be realized and how could I do it
how would I do it how can Evolution do
it what it means are it is disposal and
this determines the search space for the
things that I'm looking for but this
requires that I think in causal systems
and this thinking and causal systems is
not impossible to it's possible not to
do for a computer scientist
but it is unusual outside of computer
science and once you realize that it's
it's very weird and suddenly you have
Notions that try to replace causal
structure with say evidence and then you
notice that uh for instance evidence
medicine is is not about uh
probabilities of how something is
realized and must work like you see
people on the cruise ship getting
infected over distances and you think oh
this must be upward but no there is no
peer control study so there is no
evidence that it's airport and when you
look at resistive planes from the
outside like in this case the medical
profession or the medical messaging and
decision making or um I get terrified
because it directly affects us and in
terms of Neuroscience um of course
there's more theoretical for the most
part but there must be a reason why it's
for the most part a theoretical because
why there is no causal model that
clinicians can use to explain uh what is
happening in certain syndromes that
people are exhibiting and I noticed this
when I go to a doctor and even at a
reputable institution like Stanford that
most of the neuroscientists at some
level there are of most of the
neurologists that I'm talking towards us
at some level dual lists that they uh
don't have causal model of of the way in
which the brain is realizing things and
a lot of studies which discover that
very simple mechanisms like the ability
of human beings to use grammatical
structure are actually reflected in the
brain this is so amazing would have
thought
foreign
developments that existed in computer
science have letters on a completely
different track there is uh the
perceptron is vaguely inspired by what
the brain might be doing but I think
it's it's really a toy model or a
caricature of what cells are doing and
not in the sense that it's inferior it's
amazing what you can put forth with the
modern perceptron variations right the
current machine learning systems are
mind-blowing and what they can do but
they don't do it like biological
organisms at all it's it's very
different cells do not form change in
which they wait uh sums of real numbers
that there is something going on that is
roughly similar to it but there's a
self-organizing system that designs
itself from the inside out not by a
measure learning principle that applies
to the outside and updates weights after
reading and comparing them and Computing
gradients to the system so this
perspective of local surf organization
by reinforcement agents that try to
trade rewards with each other that is a
perspective that I find totally
fascinating and I wish this would have
come and from Neuroscience into computer
science but it hasn't there are some
people which have thought about these
ideas to some degree but there's been
very little cross-pollination and I
think all this talk of Neuroscience uh
influencing computer science is mostly
visual thinking
yeah it's also uh I find uh this you
know what you were saying about the
different disciplines it's it's kind of
amazing how uh well when I when I give a
talk
um I can always tell which department
I'm in by by which part of the talk
makes people uncomfortable and upset and
it's always different depending on which
department it is right so so there are
things you can say in one Department
that are completely obvious and you say
this in the in another group of people
and they they throw tomatoes they think
this is just crazy for instance
uh for for instance um I could I could
uh say in you know in in a neuroscience
Department I could say uh information
can be processed is without changes in
gene expression you don't need changes
in gene expression to process
information because the the the
processing inside a neural network that
runs on the physics of of action
potentials right so I mean so right so
so you can do all kinds of interesting
information processing and you don't
need genetic change sort of
transcriptional or genetic change for
that if I say the same thing in a
molecular genetics department that say
hey these cells could be processing tons
of information long before the the
transcriptome ever finds out about it
this is this is considered you know just
just completely wild because because
it's thought that that that most of the
hard work or in fact all of the hard
work is done in in gene regulatory
circuits and things like that right
there are other other examples if I say
um uh here's a uh here's a collection of
cells that communicate electrically to
to remember a particular spatial pattern
again molecular cell biology that's what
do you mean how can how can a collection
of cells remember a spatial pattern but
again in Neuroscience or in in an
engineering department yeah of course
the the of course they have electrical
circuits that remember patterns and can
do pattern completion and things like
that so
um you know views of views of causality
views of uh just just lots of things
like that that are that are very obvious
uh to one group of people is completely
taboo elsewhere so that that that
distinction and and and and yeah and as
as you as Joshua just said
um it impacts it impacts everything it
impacts education it impacts grants you
know Grant reviews because when these
kind of interdisciplinary grants come up
the study sections have a really hard
time finding people that can actually
review them because what often happens
is you'll find you'll you'll get a some
kind of computational biology Grant and
you put a proposal and you'll have some
people on the on the panel who are
biologists and some people who are the
computational folks and it's very hard
to get people that actually can
appreciate both sides of it and
understand what's happening together
right so they will sort of each critique
a certain part of it and the other part
they say I don't know what this is and
and as a result grants like that don't
tend to not have a champion you know one
person who can say no I get I get the
whole thing and I I think it's really
good or not
so yeah it's uh even to the point where
I I'm often asked you know when when
people want to you list me somewhere
they'll say so so what what what are you
you know what kind of what kind of uh
what's your field and I I never know how
to answer that question you know this
day it's been 30 years I still don't
know how to answer that question I I
just can't boil it down to one you know
it just wouldn't make any sense to to
say any of the traditional um you know
the traditional fields
so what do you say yosha when someone
asks you what field you're in
and it depends on who's asking
so for instance I found it quite useful
to sometimes say and
sorry I'm not a philosopher
um
but uh but this or
um I'm not that interested in machine
learning and I'm I did publish papers in
philosophy and in machine learning but
it's not my specialty in the sense that
I need to identify with it and
um in some sense I guess that these
categories are important when you try to
write a grant proposal or when you try
to find a job in a particular
institution and they need to fill a
position but for me it's more what
questions am I interested and what is
the thing that I want to make progress
on or what is the thing that I want to
build right now
and uh I guess that in terms of the
intersection I'm a cognitive scientist
so I was asking Michael prior to you
joining yosha why is that Michael that
you were doing podcasts and if I
understand correctly part of the reason
was because you think out loud and you
like to hear the other person's thoughts
and take notes and it Spurs your own and
firstly like Michael you can correct me
if that's incorrect and then secondly
yoksha I'm curious for an answer for
this the same question what is it that
you get out of doing podcasts other than
say some marketing for if you were
promoting something which I don't
imagine you are currently
uh no I'm not bucketing anything I uh
what I like about podcasts is the
ability to publish something in a format
that is engaging to an interesting to
people who actually care about it
I like this informal way of uh holding
on to some ideas and also like
conversations is a medium to develop
thought is this space in which we can
reflect on each other look into each
other's minds interact with the ideas of
others in real time uh the production
format of a podcast creates a certain
focus of the conversation that can be
useful and it's a pleasant kind of
tangent that focuses you to stay on task
and I also found that uh it's genuinely
useful to some people like uh with the
feedback that I get is that uh people
tell me I had this really important
question and I found this allowed me to
make a progress on it and I feel much
better now about these questions I uh
just clarified something for me that has
plagued me for years and
um put me on track to solving it or this
is inspired the following work so it's a
form of uh publishing ideas and getting
them into circulation in our Global
Health Minds that is very informal in a
way but it's not useless and also it's
uh believes me in in this instance at
least of the work of cutting editing and
so on uh but anyway so I'm very grateful
that you provide the service of curating
our conversation and putting a little
form that is useful to other people
yeah yeah there's something well the two
two things I was thinking of one is that
uh you know I mean I have conversations
with people all day long about these
issues right so people in my lab
collaborators whatever and most of
course the vast majority of those
conversations are not recorded and they
just sort of disappear into the ether
and then I I take something away from it
and the other person takes something
away from it but I've often thought that
wouldn't it be wouldn't isn't it a shame
that all of this is uh just just kind of
disappears and it would be amazing to to
have have a record of it and of course
not every conversation is you know as
gold but but but a lot of them are are
useful and interesting and uh there are
plenty of people that um could could be
interested in could could benefit from
it so so I really like this aspect that
uh we can have conversations and then
they are you know sort of canned and
they're out there for uh for for people
who are who are interested the other
kind of um aspect of it which I don't
really understand but but it's kind of
neat is that if when somebody when
somebody asks me to uh pre-record a talk
it takes crazy amount of time because
because I keep stopping and realizing I
could have said that better let me start
from the beginning and and it's just
it's it's an incredible ordeal whereas
something like this that's real time uh
I'm sure has as many you know mistakes
and things that I would have rather
fixed later but but you can't do that
right so you just sort of go with it and
that's it and then it's done and you can
move on so so I like I like that
real-time aspect of it because it just
it just helps you to get the ideas out
without getting hung up and and trying
to redo things 50 times
yeah it's a format that allows
tentativity if we have published we have
culture in sciences that requires us to
publish the things that we can hope to
prove and make the best proof that we
can but when we have anything
complicated especially when we take our
engineering stance we often cannot prove
how things work
instead our answers are in the realm of
the possible and we need to discuss the
possibilities and there is a value in
understanding these possibilities to
direct our future experiments and the
Practical work that we do to see what's
actually the case and we don't really
have a publication format for that right
we don't get neuroscientists to publish
their ideas on how the mind works
because nobody has a theory that they
can prove and as a result there is
basically a vacuum where theories should
be and the theory building happens
informally in conversations that
basically requires personal contact
which is a big issue once conference has
been virtual because that contact
diminished and you get a lot of
important ideas by reading the
Publications and so on but this uh what
could be or connecting the dots or
possibilities or ideas that might be
proven wrong later that we just exchange
as in the status of ideas that is
something that has a good place and a
podcast
now is this podcast some not this toe
podcast but podcasts in general
something new so for instance I was
thinking about this and I well podcasts
go back a while and Brogan invented this
long-form format or popularized it
however on television there are
interviews so there's Oprah and those
are long one hour they're 60 minutes and
then back in the 90s there was a three
and a half hour it's essentially a
podcast it's like Charlie Rose three and
a half hour conversation it's like a
Theo location with Freeman Dyson Daniel
Dennett Stephen J Gould like the Rupert
sheldrake all of those on the same one
format it's essentially a podcast
talking about metaphysics like man oh
man I can't believe that got published
and then also I think about it well did
Plato have the first podcast
because he's just publishing these
dialogues and you read them but it's not
as if maybe he would have published it
in video I think Plato was the first
podcaster
so is there something new about this
format of podcasting that wasn't there
before or what's new about it I think
it's like it's like vlogging uh blogging
is also not new right being able to
write text that you publish uh and uh
people can follow about your writing and
so on did exist in some sense before but
uh the internet made it possible to
publish this for everyone do you don't
need a publisher anymore and you don't
know your TV studio anymore you don't
need a broadcast station that is
recording your talk show and sends it to
an audience there is no competition with
other talk Source because uh there is no
limitations on how many people can
broadcast at the same time and this
allows an enormous diversity and of
thoughts and small Productions that are
done at a very low cost lowering the
threshold for putting something out
there and seeing what happens so in this
sense it's the ecosystem that emerged is
new because a variable change that
changed the cost of producing a talk
show
all right
Michael you agree
um yeah yeah I mean yes that and and all
of that and also just the fact that you
know uh as you as you just said uh these
kind of like long form things were
fairly rare so most of the time if
you're going to be in one of the
traditional media they tell you okay
you've got the you've got you know three
minutes uh you know we're gonna cut all
this stuff and we're gonna boil it down
to three minutes and this this is often
incredibly frustrating and and I
understand I mean we're drowned in
information and so so there's obviously
a place for very short statement on
things but the kind of stuff that we're
talking about uh cannot be boiled down
to to you know TV sound bites or
anything it's just not and and so so the
ability to have these long-form things
so that anybody who wants to really dig
in can hear what the actual thought is
as opposed to something that's that's
been just uh you know boiled into into a
very um very very short statement I
think is is invaluable just being able
to have it out there for people to find
now a brief note from two sponsors this
is a considerably easy sponsor because
some of you watching this are losing
your hair and it's not because you have
a you have trouble understanding the
content so you're pulling it out it
happens to approximately half of all men
it's uncomfortable but there are methods
to help and even to stop the process of
balding Roman offers clinically proven
medication to help treat hair loss all
of course from the comfort and privacy
of your own home Roman offers
prescription medication and
over-the-counter treatments they also
offer specially formulated shampoos and
conditioners with ingredients that
fortify and moisturize the hair to look
fuller research shows that 80 of men who
use prescription hair loss medication
had no further hair loss after two years
Roman is licensed and the whole process
is straightforward and discreet plans
start at twenty dollars a month
currently Roman has a special offer for
toe listeners that is you use the link
ro.co Kurt c-u-r-t to get 20 off your
first order again that's ro.co
c-u-r-t the link is in the description
and you get 20 off as the toe project
grows we get plenty of sponsor is coming
and I thought you know this one is a
fascinating company our new sponsor is
Masterworks Masterworks is the only
platform that allows you to invest in
multi-million dollar works of art by
Picasso bansky and more Masterworks has
given you access to invest in Fine Art
which is usually only accessible to
multi-millionaires or billionaires the
art that you see hanging in museums can
now be partially owned by you the
inventive Parts is that you don't need
to know the details of art or investing
Masterworks makes the whole process
straightforward with a clean interface
and exceptional customer service they
are innovating as more traditional
Investments suffer last month we
verified a cell which had a 21.5 percent
return so for instance if you were to
put ten thousand dollars in you would
now have twelve thousand Welcome to our
new sponsor Masterworks and the link to
them is in the description just so you
know there's in fact a wait list to join
their platform right now however total
listeners can skip the wait list by
visiting the link in the description as
well as by using the promo code theories
of everything again the link is in the
description you can see important
regulation A disclosures at Masterworks
dot com slash CD what some stance of
yours some belief that has changed most
drastically in the past few years let's
say three and it could be anywhere from
something abstruse and academic to more
colloquial like I didn't realize the
value of children or I overvalued
children now I'm stuck with them like
geez that was a mistake
yeah so something where I changed my
mind was RNA based memory transfer
and uh I think it's a super interesting
idea in this context because it's uh
close to uh stuff that Michael has been
working on and is interested in uh there
have been some experiments in the Soviet
Union I think in the 70s where
scientists look planaria uh trained them
to learn something I think they were
learned how to be afraid of electric
shocks and things like that and then
they put their uh the brains into a
blender extracted the iron a injected
other planaria visit and these other
planaria had learned it
and I I learned about this as a kid when
I in the 1980s read Soviet science
fiction into Twitter I grew up in
Eastern Germany and the evil scientist
uh harvested the brains of geniuses and
injected himself is RNA extracted from
these brains and thereby acquired the
skills and even though I'm pretty sure
it probably doesn't work if you if you
do it at this level
this was inspired by this original
research and I later heard nothing about
this anymore and so I dismissed it as uh
similar things as I read in Sputnik and
other Russian Publications which create
their own methodological Universe about
ball lightning that is authentic and
possibly sentient and so on and
dismissed this all as basically Another
Universe of another Reader's Digest
culture that is producing its own ideas
that then later on get dissolved once
science advanced answers because
everybody knows it's it's synapses it's
connections between neurons that matter
the RNA is not that important for the
information processing might change some
state but you cannot learn something by
extracting RNA and re-injecting it into
the next organism because how would that
work if it's done in the synapses
and uh then recently there were some
papers which replicated uh the original
research and has been replicated from
time to time
in different types of organisms but to
my knowledge not in of course macaques
or not even mice but so it's not clear
if their brains work according to the
same principles as planaria but planaria
are not
extremely simple organisms only a
handful of neurons there are something
intermediate with some their main
architecture is different from ours and
their functioning principles of their
neurons might be slightly different but
it's worse following this idea and going
down that rabbit hole and then I looked
for my computer science engineering
perspective and I realized that there
are always things about the synaptic
story that uh I find confusing because
they're very difficult to implement
so for instance weight sharing as a
computer scientist I require weight
sharing I don't know how to get around
this if I want to entrain myself as
computational Primitives in a local area
of of my brain for instance the ability
to rotate something which rotation is
some operator that I apply on a pattern
that allows this pattern to be
represented in a slightly different way
to have this object rotated a few
degrees but an object doesn't consist of
a single point it consists of many
features that all need to get the same
rotation applied to them using the same
mathematical Primitives so how do you
implement the same operator across an
entire brain area do you make many many
copies of the same pattern and computer
scientists solve that with so-called
convolutional neural networks which
basically use the same weights again and
again in different areas using only
training them once and making them
available everywhere and that would be
very difficult to implement and synapses
maybe there are ways but it's not
straightforward another thing is if we
see how training Works in babies they
learn something and then they get rid of
the Surplus synopsis initially they have
much more connectivity than they need
and uh when they get uh after they've
trained they optimize the way in which
the wiring works by discarding the
things they don't need to compute what
they want to compute so it's like
calling the synapses it does not uh
freeze or Edge the learning into the
brain but it optimizes the energy usage
of the brain another issue is that
patterns of activation are not
completely stable in the brain they in
the cortex if you look you find that
they might be moving the next day or
even rotate a little bit which is also
difficult to do with synapses you cannot
read out the weights and copy them
somewhere else in an easy
straightforward fashion and another
issue is defragmentation if you learn
for instance your body map into a brain
area
and then somebody changes your body map
because you have an accident and lose a
finger or somebody gives you an
artificial limp and you start to
integrate this into your body map how do
you shift all the representations around
how do you make space for something else
and move it or also initially when you
set up your Maps via happier learning
how do you make sure that the
neighborhoods are always correct and you
don't need to realign anything and I
guess you need some kind of realignment
and uh all these things seem to be
possible when you switch to a different
paradigm
and uh this so if you take this RNA
basically seriously go down this wrapper
tool what you get is
um the neurons are not learning a local
function over its neighbors but they are
learning how to respond to the shape of
an incoming activation front
right the spatial temporal pattern in
their neighborhood and they are densely
enough connected so the enabled is just
the space around them and in this space
they basically interpret this according
to a certain topology to say this uh is
maybe a convolution that gives me two
and a half D or it gives me 2D or 1D or
whatever the type of function is that
they want to compute and they learn how
to fire in this in response to those
patterns and thereby modulate the
patterns when they're passed on so the
neurons act as something like a
self-modulating ether so which waveforms
propagate that perform the computations
and they store the responses to the
distributions of incoming signals
possibly in RNA so you have little mix
tapes little tape fragments that they
store in the Soma and that you can make
more of very cheaply and easily if they
are successful mixtapes and their useful
computational Primitives that they
discovered and they can distribute this
to other neurons through the entire
cortex so new ones of the same type will
gain the knowledge to apply the same
computational Primitives
and that is something I don't know if
the brain is doing that and of the human
brain is using these principles or if
it's using them a lot and how important
this is and how many other mechanisms
exist but it's a mechanism that we
haven't so my knowledge tried very much
in Ai and computer science
and it would work there is something
that is a very close analog that is a
neural cellular automaton
here so basically instead of learning
weight uh weight shifts or weight
changes between adjacent new ones what
you learn is
um Global functions that tell neurons on
how to respond to patterns in the
neighborhood
and these functions are the same for
every point in your Matrix
and you can learn arbitrary functions in
this way and what's nice about is that
you only need to learn computational
Primitives once our kubernetworks need
to learn the same linear algebra over
and over again in many different corners
of the neural network because you need a
vector algebra for many kinds of
operations that we perform like for
instance operations in space
where we shift things around or rotate
them and if they could change exchange
these useful
um operations with each other and just
apply an operator whenever the
environment uh dictates that this would
be a good idea to try to apply this
operator right now in this context that
could speed up learning it could make uh
training much more sample efficient
right so something super interesting to
try and this is one of the rabbit holes
I recently fell down whenever I changed
my thinking based on some experiment
from Neuroscience that doesn't have very
big impact for for the mainstream of
Neuroscience but that I found reflected
in Michael's work with planaria
yeah that's that's super interesting
stuff um I I can sprinkle a few a few
details onto this um uh the original so
so the original finding in planaria was
um was a guy named James McConnell in
the in in Michigan actually in the US
and and then that was in the 60s the
early 60s and then there were some
really interesting Russian work um that
that picked it up after that uh we
reproduced some of it recently in using
modern uh modern quantitative uh
Automation and and things like this but
one of the one of the really cool
aspects of this and there's a whole
Community by the way with um you know
people like uh Randy gallistel and Sam
gershman and um you know of course
glansman David glansman and people who
are that that story of memory in the in
the precise details of the um of the
synapses is that that story is really
starting to crack actually for a number
of reasons but one of the one of the
cool things that that was done in the
Russian work and it was also done later
on by um uh Doug Blackiston who's who's
in my lab now as a staff scientist and
other people is this this you can
certain certain animals that go through
larval stages right so you can take so
what the Russians were using um beetle
beetle larvae and uh and Doug and other
people used uh used used moths and
butterflies so what happens is you train
you train the larva right so so here
you've got a butterfly a caterpillar so
so this caterpillar lives in a
two-dimensional world it's a soft-bodied
robot it lives in a two-dimensional
world that eats leaves and so on right
and so you train this thing for a
particular task well during
metamorphosis it needs to become a moth
or butterfly which it lives in a
three-dimensional world plus it's a
hard-bodied creature so so the
controller is completely different right
for running this for running a
caterpillar versus a butterfly so so
during that process what happens is the
brain is basically dissolved so most of
the connections are broken most of the
cells are gone they die uh you you put
together a brand new brain itself
assembles and you can ask all sorts of
interesting philosophical questions of
what it's like to be a creature whose
brain is undergoing this massive change
uh but the information remains and and
so one can ask okay this is you know
certainly for computer science it's it's
amazing to have a cop to have to have a
memory medium that can survive this
radical re Remodeling and reconstruction
and there's there's the RNA story but
but also
um uh you had mentioned you know does
this does this work from for mammals so
there was a guy in the 70s and 80s there
was a there was a guy named George Ungar
who did tons of he's got tons of papers
he uh reproduced it in rats so so his
was fear of the dark and he actually
um by by establishing this essay and
then
um uh you know fractionating their
brains and and extracting this this
activity now he thought it was a peptide
not not RNA so he he ended up with a
with a thing called uh scottophobin
which turns out to be I think an eight
mer peptide or something and the claim
was that you can transfer this
scotophobia you can synthesize it and
then transfer it from brain to brain and
and that's and that's you know that's
that's that's what he thought it was and
then of course I think David glansman
favors RNA again but yeah I agree with
you I think I think that's a that's a
that's a super important story of how it
is that this kind of information can
survive uh just just massive uh
remodeling of the of the cognitive
substrate in planaria what we what we
did and and planaria you know they they
have a true centralized brain they have
all the same neurotransmitters that we
have they're not as simple a simple
organism
um what we did was McConnell's first
experiments which is to train them on
something and we train them to recognize
a laser etched um kind of bumpy pattern
on the bottom of the dish to recognize
that that's where their food was going
to be found so they made this
association between this pattern and the
and getting food and then we cut their
heads off and and we took the Tails and
the Tails sit there for 10 days doing
nothing and then eventually they grow a
new brain and what happens is that
information is then imprinted onto the
new brain and then and then you can
recover behavioral you know evidence
that they remember the information
so so that's pretty cool too because it
suggests that well we don't know if the
information is everywhere or if it's in
other places in the peripheral nervous
system or in this you know in the Nerf
core that we don't know where it is yet
but it's clear that it can move around
that the information can move around in
the body because it can be in the
posterior half and then imprinted onto
the brain which actually drives all the
all the behaviors
so thinking about that I I totally agree
that this is this is a really important
rabbit hole for asking but but it has it
there's an interesting puzzle here which
which is which is this you know it's one
thing to remember things that are
evolutionarily uh adaptive like fear of
the dark and things like this but
imagine and this hasn't really been done
well but imagine for a moment if we
could train them to something that is
completely novel let's say let's say we
train them um uh three yellow life
flashes means so take a step to your
left otherwise you get shocked something
like that and let's say they learn to do
it we haven't done this yet but let's
say let's say this could be could work
one of the big uh puzzles is going to be
when you extract whatever it is that you
extract let's say it's RNA or protein
whatever it is you stick it into the
brain of a recipient host and in order
for that memory to transfer one of the
things that the host has to be able to
do is has to be able to decode it in
order to decode it it's one thing if we
share the same code book and by
Evolution we could have this same code
book for things that come up all the
time like fear of the dark fear you know
things like that but how do you how how
would the recipient look at a a a a
weird sort of you know some some kind of
crazy hairpin RNA structure and look at
and and analyze it and be like oh yes
that's three light flashes and then uh
step to the left I see so you would need
to be able to interpret somehow this the
structure and convert it back to the
behavior and for and for behaviors that
are truly arbitrary that might be I I
don't know actually how that would work
and so so I think the frontier of this
field is going to be to have a really uh
convincing demonstration of of a
transfer of a memory that doesn't have a
plausible pre-existing shared
evolutionary decoding because because
otherwise you have a you have a real
puzzle as to how the how the the
decoding is going to work so this this
idea and and then and then even without
the transfer you can also think of it a
different way every memory is like a
message is like basically a transplanted
message from your past self to your
future self meaning that you still have
to decode your memories whatever your
memories are in an important sense you
have to you know those engrams you have
to decode them somehow so
um that that whole issue of of encoding
and decoding whatever the substrate of
memory is is you know maybe one of the
most important questions there are
one of the ways I we can think about
these engrams I think that there are
priors that condition what kinds of
features are being spawned in which
context for instance when we see a new
scene the way that perception seems to
be working is that we uh spawn lots lots
of feature controllers that then
organize into objects that are
controlled at the level of the scene
and uh this is basically a game engine
that is forming in our brain that is
creating a population of interacting
objects that are tuned to track our
perceptual data at the lowest level so
all the patterns that we get from our
retina and so on uh are samples noisy
samples
um that are difficult to interpret but
we are matching them into these
hierarchies of features that are
translated into objects that assign
every feed a feature to exactly one
object and every pixel so to speak to
exactly one except in the case of
transparency and use this to interpret
the scene that is happening in front of
us and when we are in the dark
what happens is that we spawn lots of
object controllers without being able to
disprove them because there is no data
that forces us to reject them and if you
have a vivid imagination especially as a
child you will feel this Darkness
automatically with lots of objects many
of which will be scary
and so I think that lots of the fear of
the dark doesn't need a lot of encoding
in our brain it is just an artifact of
the fact that there are scary things in
the world which I learned to represent
at an early age and that we cannot
disprove them that they just will just
spawn
I remember this vividly as a child that
whenever I had to go into the dark
basement to uh get some food in our
house uh in the countryside that this
Darkness automatically filled with all
sorts of shapes and things and
possibilities
and it took me later to learn that uh
you need to be much more afraid of the
ghosts that can hide in the light
so what would be the implications of if
you were able to transfer memory for
something that's
not trivial so nothing that's like an
archetype of fear of the dark between
a mammal like rats
and when I say transfer memory I mean in
this way that you blend up the brain or
you and also can you explain what's
meant by I think I understand what it
means to blend the brain of a planaria
but I don't think that's the same
process that's going on in rats maybe it
is they they well ongar did exactly the
same thing he would train rats for
particular tasks he would extract the
brain literally liquefy to extract the
chemical contents uh he would then
either inject the whole extract or a
filtered extract where you would divide
it up you'd fractionated so here's the
rnas here's the proteins here you know
other things uh and and then he would
inject that liquid directly into the
brains of recipient rats so you know
when you do that you lose you lose
spatial structure on the input because
you just Blended your brain whatever
spatial structure otherwise you just
destroyed it also on the recipient you
just you just inject it it's not you
know you're not finding that particular
place where you're going to stick that
you just inject this this thing right in
the middle of the brain who knows where
it goes you know where the fluid goes is
it sort of there's no spatial
specificity there whatsoever so if that
works uh what you're counting on is the
ability of the brain to take up
information via a completely novel route
so it's not information that's for
example visual right visual information
the accounts it comes in exactly the
same place all the time right there are
there are there are optic nerves that
connect to the same place in the in the
brain and that's where that information
arrives if you bathe the brain in some
sort of uh informational extract you're
basically asking the cells to take it up
almost as as a primitive animal would
with taste or touch you right that's
kind of distributed all over the body
and you can sort of pick it up anywhere
and then you have to process this
information so so you've got those
issues right off the bat right that
you've destroyed the incoming spatial
structure you you can't really count on
where it's going to land in the brain
and and then the third thing is as you
just mentioned is the idea that
especially if we start with information
that isn't any that is is that is so um
uh kind of uh specific and
um
you know kind of uh invented you know
that free light flashes means move to
your left I mean there's never there's
never been an evolutionary reason to
have that encoded like as you just said
having a fear of the dark is absolutely
a natural kind of thing that shows that
that you can expect but and then there
are many other things like that but but
something something as as contrived as
as you know three light flashes and then
you move to your left there's no reason
to think that we have a built-in way to
recognize that so when you as a as a
recipient brain are handed this weird uh
molecule with a particular structure or
or a set of molecules uh being able to
analyze that having the cells in your
brain or or other parts of the body
actually that could Analyze That and
recover that original information would
be extremely puzzling I actually don't
know how that would work and I'm a big
fan of of unlikely sounding experiments
that have implications if they would
work so this is something that uh that I
think should absolutely be done and um
and you know at some point we'll we'll
do it but we haven't done it yet but so
how far did the research in my school
what is the complexity of things that
could be transmitted via this road the I
as as I I don't remember everything that
he did uh the vast majority of he he did
not
um go
far to test all the complexities what he
tried to do was because as you can
imagine he faced incredible opposition
right so so everybody you know sort of
wanted to critique this thing so he
spent all of his time on he picked one
simple assay which was this fear of the
dark thing and then he just he just
bashed it for for 20 years uh to just
finally try to kind of crack that into
the into the Paradigm he did not
um as far as I know do lots of different
assays to try and make it more complex I
think uh I think it you know it's it's
very ripe for for investigation uh this
is the kind of did anyone else build
upon his work
um not that I know I mean I mean David
glansman is the best modern person who
works on this right so he does aplizia
and he you know and he does RNA so so he
favors um he favors RNA
um there's a little bit of work from um
in Israel with C elegans uh he's kind of
looking into that it uh there's related
work that has to do with cryogenics
which is this this you know this idea
idea that that if if it is if if
memories are a particular kind of
dynamic electrical State then some sort
of cryogenic freezing is probably going
to disrupt that whereas if it's a stable
molecule then it should survive so again
I think there are people interested in
that aspect of it but I'm not sure
um I'm not sure they've done anything
with it there's also a goraf uh
venkataraman I think he's oh yes yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah he uh taught me that
uh he has been working on this for
several years but he said It's
sociologically Tricky and that's to me
fascinating that we should care about
that what does he mean by that what do
you care about what stupid people think
uh if this uh possibility exists that
this works the upside is so big that
it's criminal to not research this I I
think it's a disaster that you can read
uh introductory textbooks on your
residence and never ever hear about any
of these experiments yeah yeah like uh
everybody who gets the introductory
stuff on Neuroscience only knows about
uh information stored in the connect
home and this leads to for instance the
blue brain project if that if RNA based
memory transfer is a thing then this
entire project is doomed and because you
cannot get the story out of uh just
recording the contact home or the most
of the research right now is focused on
reconstructing The Chronic tone as as it
was circuitry and hoping that we can get
the functionality of information
processing and to use the specificity of
the particular brain what it has learned
from the connections between neurons but
what if it turns out this doesn't matter
what is if you just need a connection
that dense enough and so basically
stochastic lattice that is somewhat
randomly wired and what matters is what
the new ones are doing with the
information that they're getting through
this ether to this lattice right this
changes the entire way in which we need
to look at things and if this
possibility exists and if this
possibility it's just one percent but
there is some experimentice points in
this direction it is not
um it's ridiculous to not pursue this
with high pressure and focus on it and
support research that goes in this
direction basically what's useful is not
so much answering questions in science
it's discovering questions it's
discovering new uncertainty reducing the
uncertainty is much easier than
discovering new areas of where you
thought that you were certain
but that allow you to get new insights
and it seems to me that a lot of
Neuroscience is stuck that does not
produce uh results that seem to
accumulate in an obvious way towards a
theory on how the brain processes
information yeah so the Neuroscience I
just don't deliver input to the
researchers and add the Transformer is
not the result of uh reading a lot of
Neuroscience it's really mostly the
result of people thinking about
statistics of data processing and it
would be great if we would focus on
ideas that are promising and new and
that have the power to shake existing
paradigms yeah this is you know this is
this is so important and it's not just
Neuroscience in developmental biology we
have exactly the same thing and and I'll
just give you two two very simple
examples of it where and I tell the
students when I when I give talks to
students I say isn't it amazing that
that in in your whole
course of biology in your developmental
biology textbook there's not a mention
of any of this because it completely um
uh just undermines a lot of the basic
assumptions so here's a couple of
examples one one example is that as of
trophic memory and deer so there are
species of deer that every year they
regenerate that you know the whole so
they make this antler rack on their
heads the whole thing falls off and then
it regrows the next year so these two
guys bubenic which are the Father and
Son team that did these experiments for
40 years and actually have all these
antlers in my lab now because when when
the younger one retired I asked he sent
me all these things all these antlers
the idea is this um what you can do is
you take a knife and somewhere in this
Branch structure you you make a wound
and the bone will heal and you get a
little callous and that's you know
that's it for that year then the whole
thing drops off and then next year
it starts to grow and it will make an
ectopic tine an ectopic Branch at the
point where you injured it last year and
this goes on for five or six years and
then eventually it goes away and and and
you get a normal normal rack again and
so the the amazing thing about it is
that you know as you you could you can
you can the the the standard models for
for patterning for morphogenesis are
these kind of um Gene regulatory
networks and and you know genetic um
Kinds of Kinds of uh biochemical
gradients and so on you know if you try
to try to come up with a with a with a
model for this so for for encoding an
arbitrary Point within a branch
structure that your cells at the scalp
have to remember for months after the
whole thing is dropped off and then not
only remember it but then implement it
so that when the bone starts to grow
something says oh yes that's the you
know the start another another time
growing to your left exactly exactly
here right trying to trying to make a
model of this using the standard tools
of the field is uh just just incredibly
difficult and and this is that that's
and there are other examples of this but
this kind of
non-non-genetic memory that's just very
difficult to explain with standard
models the other thing which is any I
think an even bigger Scandal is the
whole situation with planaria
um
planaria some species of planaria the
way they reproduce is they tear
themselves in half each half regenerates
the missing piece and now you've got two
that's how they reproduce so if you're
going to do that what you end up
avoiding is weissman's barrier this idea
that when we get mutations in our body
our children don't inherit those
mutations right so this means that any
mutation that doesn't kill the stem cell
in the body gets Amplified as that cell
contributes to regrowing the worm so
every as a result of this for for 400
million years these planaria have
accumulative mutations their genomes are
an incredible mess their cells are
basically mixoploid that meaning meaning
they're like a tumor every cell has a
different number of chromosomes
potentially they just they just look
look you know it just looks horrible as
an end result you've got an animal that
is Immortal incredibly good at
regenerating with 100 Fidelity and very
resistant to cancer now this is all of
this is the exact opposite of the
message you get uh from from from a
typical course through through biology
which it says that what is the genome
for The genome is for setting your body
structure if you mess with the genome
that information goes away you get you
get aging you get cancer right why does
the animal with the worst genome have
the the the best anatomical Fidelity I
mean that's just that and and I think we
actually as of as of you know a few
months ago we actually I think have some
insight into this but but but it's been
bugging me for for years and this is the
kind of thing that nobody ever talks
about because it it goes against the
general Assumption of what of what
genomes actually do and and what they're
for and you know this this complete lack
of uh correlation between the genome in
fact an anti-correlation between the
genome quality and the incredible
ability of this of this animal to uh to
to to to to have a healthy Anatomy yeah
what is that Insight that you mentioned
you acquired a few months ago
preliminary so so okay uh in the in the
name of uh you know throwing out uh kind
of new unproven ideas right so this is
you know this this is this is just my my
conjecture we've we've done some we've
done some computational modeling of it
which which I initially this was a um a
very uh clever student that I work with
named lakshman who I did did some models
with me and uh uh I initially thought it
was a bug and then I realized that no
actually this is this is this is the
feature the idea is this imagine so so
we've been working for a long a long
time on a concept of
um competency among embryonic parts and
what this means is basically the idea
that uh there are there are um
homeostatic feedback loops among various
cells and tissues and organs that
attempt to reach specific outcomes in
anatomical amorphous space despite
various perturbations so the idea is
that if you have a tadpole and you do
something to it whether by a mutation or
by a drug or something you do something
to it where the eye is a little
off-kilter or the mouth is a little off
all of these organs pretty much know
where they're supposed to be they will
try to minimize distance from other um
landmarks and they will Remodel and
eventually you get a normal frog so that
so that they will they will sort of
um a a recover the correct uh Anatomy
despite starting off in the wrong
position or even things like changes in
the number of cells or the size of cells
they're really good at getting their job
done despite various changes right so
okay so they have these competencies to
optimize specific uh things like like
their position and structure and things
like that
so uh so so that's so that's competency
now now here's here's the interesting
thing
imagine that you have a species that uh
has some some degree of that competency
and so you've got an individual of that
species comes up for selection uh
Fitness is high looks pretty good but
here's the problem selection doesn't
know whether the fitness is high because
his genome was amazing or the fitness is
high because the genome was actually so
so but the competency sort of made up
for it and now everything kind of got
back to where it needs to go so what the
competency apparently does is Shield
information from Evolution about the
actual genome it makes it harder to pick
the best genomes because you're
individuals that perform well don't
necessarily have the best genomes what
they do have is competency so what
happens and what happens in our
simulations is that when if you start
off with even a little bit of that
competency Evolution loses some power in
selecting the best genomes but it but
but where all the work tends to happen
is increasing the competency
so then the competency goes up so the
cells are even better at and the tissues
are even better at getting the job done
despite the bad genome that makes it
even worse that that that that that that
makes it even harder for for evolution
to see the best genomes which relieves
some of the pressure on having a good
genome but it basically puts all the
pressure on being really competent so
you've got this so so basically what
happens is that uh the the the genetic
fitness basically levels out at a really
sub-optimal level and in fact the
pressure is off of it so so it's
tolerant all kinds of craziness but the
competency and the mechanisms of
Competency get get pushed up really high
so in many animals and but there are
other factors that sort of push against
this ratchet but it becomes it becomes a
positive feedback loop it becomes a
ratchet for Optimal Performance despite
a sub-optimal genome and so in some
animals this sort of evens out at a
particular point but I think what
happened in planaria is that this whole
process ran away to its ultimate
conclusion the ultimate conclusion is
the competency algorithm became so good
that basically whatever the genome is
it's really good at creating and
maintaining a proper worm because it is
already being evolved in the presence of
a genome whose quality we cannot control
so so in computer science speak it's
kind of like um and Steve Frank put me
onto this analogy it's kind of like what
happens in raid arrays when you have a
nice raid array where the software makes
sure that you don't lose any data the
pressure is off to have really uh really
high quality media and so now you can
tolerate you can tolerate media with
lots of mistakes because because the
software takes care of it in the in the
raid and the on the architecture takes
care of it so so basically what happens
is you've got this animal where that uh
that runaway uh feedback loop went went
so far that the algorithm is amazing and
it's been it's been uh evolved
specifically for the ability to do what
it needs to do even though the hardware
is kind of crap and and it's it's
incredibly tolerant so this has a number
of implications that that to my
knowledge have never been explained
before for example in every kind every
other kind of animal you can you can
call a stock Center and you can get
mutants so you can get mice with with
kinky kind of Kink tails you can get
flies with red eyes and you can get uh
chickens without toes and you can get
you know humans come with that it has
various you know albinos and things you
can you can there's there's always
mutants that you can get uh planaria
there are no there are no abnormal lines
of planaria anywhere except for the only
exception is our two-headed line and
that that one's not genetic that one's
that one's bioelectric so so isn't it
amazing that that that nobody has been
able despite despite a hundred and you
know I don't know 120 years of
experiments with planaria nobody has
isolated a uh a line of planaria that is
anything other than a perfect planarian
I think this is why I think it's because
they have been actually selected for
being able to do what they need to do
despite the fact that there the the
hardware is just very junky and so so
that's my that's my current that's my
current current take on it and and and
really uh it puts more kind of more
emphasis on on on the algorithm and the
decision making among that cellular
Collective of what what you know what
are we going to build and what's the
algorithm for for making sure that we're
all working to build the correct thing
so if you translate this idea into
computer science a way to look at it is
imagine that you find some computers
that have
um artists that are very very noisy and
where the heart is basically makes lots
and lots of mistakes in encoding things
and bits often flip and so on and you
will find that these computers still
work and they work on pretty much the
same way as the other computers that you
have and there is an orthodox sect of
computer scientists that thinks uh it is
necessary that uh the every bit on the
hard disk is completely reliable or
reliable to such a degree that you only
have a mistake once every 100 trillion
copies and you can have an error
correction quote running on the hard
disk at the low level that corrects this
and after some point it doesn't become
efficient anymore so you need to have
reliable hard disks to be able to have
computers that work like this but uh how
would these other computers work and it
basically means that you create a
virtual structure on top of the noisy
structure that is correcting for
whatever degree of um uncertainty you
have or the degree of Randomness that
gets injected into your substrate David
Dave Eckley has a very nice metaphor for
this you know maybe yeah yeah he's a I
think a beautiful artist who explores
complexity by tinkering with
computational models I really find this
work very inspiring and he has this idea
of best effort Computing so in his view
our own nervous system is a best effort
computer it's one that does not rely on
the other neurons around you working
perfectly uh but make an effort to be
better than random and then you stack
the improbabilities empirically by
having a system that evolves to measure
in effect the unreliability of its
components and then stack the
probabilities until you get the system
to be deterministic enough to do what
you're doing with what to do with it
right so you uh if you have a system
that is as in a planaria inherently very
noisy where the genome is an unreliable
witness of what should be done and the
body you just need to interpret it in a
way that Stacks the probabilities that
is evaluating things with much more
error tolerance and maybe this is always
the case maybe there is a Continuum
um maybe not it's also possible that
there is some kind of phase shift where
your switch from organisms with reliable
genomes to organisms with noisy genomes
and you would basically use a completely
different way to construct the organism
as a result but it's a it's a very
interesting hypothesis then to see if if
this is a radical thing or a gradual
thing that happens on all organisms to
some degree yeah what I also like about
this uh description that you give about
how the organism emerges it maps on in
some sense also in how perception Works
in in our own mind at the moment measure
learning is mostly focused on
recognizing images
so our individual frames and the you
feed in information frame by frame and
the information is relatively
disconnected from a system like Delhi 2
is trained by giving it several hundreds
of millions of images
and they are disconnected the they're
not adjacent images in the space of
images and a baby could not probably
learn from giving 600 million images in
a dark room and only looking at this
introduce the structure of the world
from this whereas Delhi can which gives
Testament to the power of our
statistical methods and Hardware that we
have that far surpasses I think the
combined power and valuability of brains
which probably would not be able to
integrate so much information over such
a big distance
for us the world is learnable because
it's adjacent frames are correlated
basically information gets preserved in
the world so time and we only need to
learn the way in which the information
gets transmogorified
and these transformifications of
information means that we have a dynamic
World in which the static image is an
exception the identity function is a
special case of how the universe changes
and we mostly learn change we just got
visited by my cat and my cat has
difficulty to recognize static objects
compared to moving objects where it's
much much easier to see a moving ball
than a ball that is laying still yeah
and it's because it's much easier to
segment it out the environment when it
moves right so the task of learning on a
moving environmental Dynamic environment
is much easier because it imposes
constraints on the world and so how do
we represent a moving world compared to
a static well the semantics of features
changes and the uh an object is
basically composed of features that are
there can be objects themselves and the
scene is the decomposition of all the
features that we see into a complete set
of objects that explain the entirety of
the scene and the interaction between
them and causality is the interaction
between objects right and in a static
image these objects don't do anything
they don't interact with each other they
just stand in some kind of relationship
that you need to infer which is super
difficult because you only have this
static snapshot and so the features are
classifiers that tell you how to whether
a feature is a hand or a foot or a pen
or a Sun or a flashlight or whatever and
how they relate to the larger scene in
which again you have a static
relationship in which you need to
classify the objects based on the
features that contribute to them and you
need to find some kind of description
where you interpret the features which
are usually ambiguous and could be many
different things depending on the
context which you interpret them into
one optimal Global configuration right
but if scene is moving this changes a
little bit what happens now is that the
features become operators they're no
longer classifiers that tell you how
your internal State needs to change how
your world needs to change or your
simulation of the universe in your mind
needs to change to track the sensory
patterns right so a feature now is an
change operator a transformation
and uh the feature is in some sense a
controller that tells you how the bits
are moving and in your local model of
the universe and they are organized in a
hierarchy of controllers
and these controllers need to be turned
on and off at the level of the scene and
they have a lot of flexibility once you
have them they can move around in the
scene they're basically no
self-organizing self-stabilizing
entities in the same way as the mouse is
moving around in your organism a feature
can move around in the organism and
shift itself around to communicate with
other features until they negotiate a
valid interpretation of reality
that's that's incredibly interesting
because I you know as soon as you
started saying that uh I was starting to
think that the the virtualization that
enables right so the earlier part of
which we're saying the virtualization of
um
uh the the information that allows you
to
um deal with with unreliable hardware
and everything the the bioelectric uh
circuits that we deal with are a great
candidate for that because actually we
see exactly that we see a bioelectric
pattern that is very resistant to
changes in the details and make sure
that everybody does the right thing
under a wide range of you know different
defects and so on but but but even more
than that the other thing that what you
were just um emphasizing this the fact
that we learned the Delta right and that
and that we're looking for change very
interesting if you if you pivot the
whole thing from the temporal domain to
the spatial domain so so in development
what we we when we look at these
bioelectric patterns now now these
patterns are across space not across
time so so on like a neuroscience where
everything is kind of in the temporal
domain for neurons these things these
are voltage static voltage patterns
across tissue right across the whole
thing so for the longest time you know
we asked this question how are these
read out what how do cells actually read
these because because one possibility
early this was a very early hypothesis
you know 20 years ago was that maybe the
local voltage tells every cell what to
be so it's like a paint by numbers kind
of thing and every and and each voltage
you know each voltage value corresponds
to some kind of outcome that turned out
to be false what we did find is that
there and we have computational models
of how this works now
um what is read out is the Delta the
difference between regions it doesn't
care nobody cares about what the
absolute voltage is what what what is
read out in terms of outcomes for for
Downstream cell Behavior gene expression
all that what is actually right out is
the voltage difference between two
adjacent domains so that is exactly
actually what it's doing just in a
spatial domain it it only keys off of
the Delta and what is in what is learned
from that is um exactly just as as you
as you were saying it modifies uh the
controller for for what's Downstream of
that and there may be multiple ones that
are sort of moving around in Cohen
having I mean it's a very it's a very
compelling
um picture actually and way to look at
some of the some of the simulations that
that we've been doing about how the
bioelectric data are interpreted by the
rest of the cells you know it's very
interesting could we take a couple of
couple minute break yeah sure I'll get a
new coffee all right
speaking of coffee a brief note from our
sponsor
coffee helps me work it helps me fast
from carbs it's become one of the best
parts of my day consistently that's why
I'm delighted that we're collaborating
with Trade coffee they partner with top
independent Roasters to Freshly roast
and send the finest coffee in the
country directly to your home on your
preferred schedule this matters to me as
I work from home their team of experts
do all the work testing hundreds of
disparate coffees to land on a final
curated collection of 450 exceptional
coffees I chose these three and the team
at Trade coffee worked to create a
special lineup for theories of
everything for the tow audience based on
some questions they asked me such as how
much caffeine do I enjoy and what's the
bitterness ratio Etc you can get that
line up or if that's not let's say your
cup of coffee then you can take your own
quiz on their website to find a set that
matches your specific profile if you'd
like to support small businesses and
Brew the best cup of coffee you've ever
made at home then it's time to try Trade
coffee right now trade is offering our
listeners thirty dollars off your first
order plus free shipping at
drinktrade.com everything that's
drinktrade.com everything for thirty
dollars off so Professor Levin use the
word competence earlier and I'd like you
to Define that
yeah
um
I in order to Define it uh I I want to
put out two two concepts to this one one
idea is that to me and this goes back to
what we were talking about before is the
engineering stance on things I
think that useful cognitive claims such
as something you know when you say this
system has whatever or it can whatever
right as far as various types of
cognitive capacities I think those kind
of claims are really engineering uh
claims that is when you tell me that
something is competent at a particular
level maybe right so so you can think
about like like wiener and rosenberg's
scale of
cognition that goes from simple um you
know simple passive materials and then
reflexes and then all the way up to kind
of second order metacognition and all
that when you tell me that something is
on that ladder and where it is what
you're really telling me is if I want to
predict Its Behavior or I want to use it
in an engineering context or I want to
interact with it or relate to it in some
way this is what I can expect so right
so that's what you really telling me so
all of these terms what they really are
are engineering protocols so if you tell
me that something has the capacity to do
um a associate of learning or or
whatever what you're telling me is that
hey you can do something more with this
than you could with a mechanical clock
you can provide certain types of uh
stimuli or experiences and you can
expect that to do this or that
afterwards or if you tell me that
something is a um a homeous you know a
homeostat that means that hey I can
count on it to keep some variable in at
a particular range without having to be
there myself to control it all the way
it has a certain autonomy now how much
right and if you tell me that something
is really intelligent and it can do XYZ
then I know that okay you're telling me
that it has even more autonomous
behavior in certain contexts so so all
of these terms to me what they really
are they're not and that has an
important implication the implication is
that they're Observer dependent that
that that that you you've picked some
kind of problem space you've picked uh
some kind of perspective and from that
problem problem space in that
perspective you're telling me that with
with sort of given certain goal States
this system has that much competency to
pursue those gold States and different
observers can have different views on
this for any given system so for example
somebody might look at a brain like
let's say a human brain and say well I'm
pretty sure the only thing this is this
is a paperweight so it's really pretty
much just competent in going down
gravitational gradient so all I can do
is hold down paper that's it and
somebody else will look at and say ah
you missed the whole point you missed
the whole point this thing is
competencies in behavioral space and
linguistic space right so these are all
um empirically testable uh engineering
claims about what you can expect the
system to do so when I say competency
what I mean is we specify a space a
problem space and at the time when we
were talking about this the problem
space that I was talking about was the
the anatomical morphe space that was the
space we were talking about so so the
space of possible anatomical
configurations and specifically
navigating that morph of space so you
start off as an egg or you start off as
a damaged limb or whatever and you
navigate that morphe space into the
correct structure so so when I say
competency I mean you have the ability
to deploy certain kinds of tricks to
navigate that amorphous space with some
level of uh performance that I can count
on and so the competency might be really
low or it might be really high then I
would have to make specific claims about
what I mean here's an example of a
compound and there are many you know if
you just think about the Behavioral
Science of navigation there are many
competencies you can think about does it
you know does it does it know ahead of
time where it's going does it have a
memory of where it's been or is it a
very simple you know sort of reflex arc
is all it has or um here's one one
example of a pretty cool competency that
um that that a lot of biological systems
have
if we take some cells that are in the
tail of a tadpole and we
give them a particular we we modify
their ion channels uh with such that
they now acquire
um a a the goal of navigating to an eye
fate in more in in this morphe space
meaning that they're going to make an
eye these things in fact will create an
eye and they'll make an eye in the tail
on the gut wherever you want but one of
the cool and so that's already pretty
pretty cool but but one of the amazing
aspects is if I only modify a few cells
not enough to make an actual eye just
just a handful of cells and we've done
this and you can see this work
one of the competencies they have is to
recruit local neighbors that were
themselves not in any way manipulated to
help them achieve that goal it's a
little bit like in an ant colony right
there's a there's this idea of
Recruitment and ants and termites is an
idea of recruitment where where
individuals can can recruit others and
you know talk about a flexible
collective intelligence this is it this
is they they you you've re-specified the
goal for that set of cells but one of
the things that they do without us
telling them how to do it or having to
micromanage it they already have the
competency to recruit as many cells as
they need to get the job done so that's
a very nice for an engineer that's a
very nice competency because it means
that I don't need to worry about taking
care of getting exactly the right number
of cells if I'm if I'm a little bit over
that's fine if I'm way under also fine
the system has that competency of
recruiting other cells to get the job
done so so that's what I so that's what
I meant so to me to make an um any kind
of a cognitive claim you have to specify
the problem space you have to specify
the goal goal towards which it's
expressing competencies and that may
right and and then and then you can make
a claim about well how competent is it
to get to that goal and somebody I wish
I could remember who it was but somebody
made this really nice analogy about kind
of the ends of that spectrum they said
two magnets try to get together and
Romeo and Juliet try to get together but
the degree of flexible problem solving
that you can expect out of those two
systems is incredibly different and
within that range there are all kinds of
in-between systems that may be better or
worse and may deploy different kinds of
strategies you know can they avoid local
Optima can they have a memory of the
where they've been can they look further
than their local environment a million
different things so that's that's what I
meant by competency it's it's it's it's
a claim about what and what an engineer
can expect the system to do given a
particular problem space in a particular
goal that you think it's uh trying to
reach
so the way in which you use the word
competency could be treated as the
capacity of a system for adaptive
control
yeah yeah yeah
one uh issue that I have with the notion
of goals and goal directedness is that
sometimes you only have a tendency in a
system to go in a certain direction and
so it's it's directed but the goal is
something that can be emergent sometimes
it's not sometimes there is an explicit
representation in the system of a
discrete event that is associated or a
class of events this fulfilling a
certain condition that the system has
committed itself to and if you don't
have that you don't have a proper goal
but in real systems it's difficult to
say I mean when do we pursue goals right
sometimes we just are vaguely hungry are
moving towards the kitchen because we
hope that something will
opportunistically emerge that will deal
with this vague tendency in our Behavior
we could also say we have the goal of
finding food but uh that is a
rationalization that is maybe stretching
sick sometimes yeah so uh sometimes a
better distinction for me is
going from a simple controller to an
agent and I try to because we are very
good at discovering agency in the world
what does it actually mean when we
discover agency and when we discover our
own agency and start to amplify it
um
by making models of who we are and how
we deal with the world and with others
and so on the minimal definition of
agent that I found it's a controller for
future States
the thermostat doesn't have a goal by
itself right it just has a Target value
and a sensor that tells the deviation
from the target value and when that
exceeds a certain threshold the heating
is turned on and if it goes below a
certain threshold the heating is turned
off again and this is it so the
thermostat is not an age and it only
reacts to the present frame it's only a
reactive system
whereas an agent is proactive which
means that it's trying to um not just
minimize the current deviation from the
target value but the integral over at
the time span previously the future
deviation so it builds an expectation
about how uh an action is going to
change this trajectory of the universe
and over that trajectory it tries to
figure out some measure of how big the
compound Target deviation is going to be
and so as a result you get a branching
universe and the branches in this
universe some of these branches depend
on actions that are available to you and
that translate into decisions that you
can make that uh move you into more or
less preferable wealth States and
suddenly you have a system with emergent
beliefs desires and intentions but to
make that happen to move from a
controller to agency and agent has been
a controller with an integrated setpoint
generator and the ability to control
future states that requires that you can
make models that are counterfactual so
because the future universe doesn't
exist right now you need to create a
counterfactual universe The Future model
of the future Universe maybe even a
model of the past universe that allows
you to reason about possible for future
universes and so on and to make these
counter factual causal models of the
universe you need to have a turing
machine
so without a computer without something
that is too incomplete that insulates
you from the causal structure of your
substrate that allows you to build
representations regardless of what the
universe says right now around you right
you need to have that machine and the
simplest uh system in nature that has
turing machine integrated is the cell
so uh it's very difficult to find a
system in nature that is an agent that
is not made from cells as a result
maybe there are systems in nature that
are able to uh compute things and make
models but uh I I'm not aware of any so
the simplest one that I know that can do
this reliably is the cells or
arrangement of sets and that can possess
agency which is interesting thing that
explains this coincidence that living
things are agents and vice versa that
the agent that we discover are mostly
living things or there are robots that
have computers built into them or uh
virtual robots that have that rely on
computation so the ability to make
models of the future is the prerequisite
for agency and to make arbitrary models
which means structures that embody uh
causal uh simulations of some sort that
requires computation
yeah yeah um you know I'm on board with
that with that ladder of that that
taxonomy uh of of uh
of of goals and so on one one
interesting thing about uh about goals
and as you say some are emergent and and
some are not there's a there's an
interesting uh planarian
um uh version of this which is which is
this we
we made this hypothesis about so so with
implant area you chop it up into pieces
and every piece regenerates exactly the
right rest of the work right so if it's
if if you chop it into pieces each piece
will have one head one tail so and then
and then of course what happens is it
stops when it when it may when it
reaches a correct planarian then then it
stops and so so we started to think that
there are two there are a couple of
possibilities one possibility is that
this is a purely emergent process and
that the goal of rebuilding ahead is is
an emergent thing that comes about as a
consequence of other things or could
there be a an actual explicit
representation of what a correct
planarian is that serves as a set point
as an encoded as an explicitly encoded
set point for these cells to follow and
and because it's a cellular a collective
we're communicating electrically we
thought well maybe maybe what it's doing
is basically storing a memory of what
did you like you would in in a neural
circuit you're storing a memory of what
it should be so we started looking for
this and this is what we found and this
is this is kind of I think one type of
one one important type of goal in a in a
goal seeking system is is a is a goal
that you can rewrite without changing
the hardware and the system will now
pursue that goal instead of something
else in a purely emergent system that
doesn't work right if you have a
cellular automaton or a fractal or
something that that does some kind of
complex thing if you want to change what
that complex thing is you have to figure
out what the local rule how to change
the local rules that's very hard in most
cases but what we found in planaria is
that we can literally using a voltage
reporter die we can look at the worm and
we can see now the pattern the the and
it's a distributed pattern but we can
see the pattern that tells this animal
how many heads it's supposed to have and
what you can do is you can go in and
using a a brief transient uh
manipulation of the ion Channels with
drugs with ION channel drugs that and we
have a computational model that tells
you what those drugs should be that
bring briefly changes the electrical
state of the circuit but the circuit is
amazing it's it it once you've changed
that state it holds so so by default it
in a standard planarian it always says
one head but but it's kind of like a
flip-flop in that when you you
temporarily shift it it holds and you
can push it to a to a state that says
two heads so now something very
interesting happens
um two interesting things one is that if
you if you take those worms and you cut
those into pieces you get two-headed
worms even though the genetics are the
hardware is all wild type there's
nothing wrong with Hardware all the
proteins are the same all the genetics
is the same but the electric circuit now
says make two heads instead of one and
so this is in in an interesting way it
is an explicit goal because you can
rewrite it because much like with your
thermostat there's an interface for
changing what the goal state is and then
you don't even need to know how the rest
of the thermostat works as long as you
know how to use your how to modify that
interface the system takes care of the
rest the other interesting thing is and
and I love what you said about the
counter factuals what you can do is you
can change that electrical pattern in an
intact worm
and not cut it for a long time and if
you do that when you look at that
pattern that is a counter factual
pattern because that two-headed pattern
is not a readout of the current state it
says two heads but the animal only has
one head it's a normal planarian so the
that pattern memory is not a readout of
what the animal is doing right now it is
a representation of what the animal will
do in the future if it happens to get
injured and you may never cut it or you
may cut it but if you do then the
pattern becomes uh then the cells
consult a pattern and build a two-headed
worm and then it becomes a you know the
current state but until then it's this
weird like primitive
um uh it's a primitive counterfactual
system because it's able to a body of a
planarian is able to store at least two
different
representations of what probably many
more but we found two so far what a
correct planarian should look like it
can have a memory of a one-headed
planarian or a memory of a two-headed
planarian and and and both of those can
live in exactly the same Hardware in
exactly the same the same body the other
kind of cool thing about this and um
I'll just mention this even though this
is this is you know disclaimer this is
not published yet so this is uh you know
take all this with a grain of salt the
the but but the the latest thing you can
do is you can actually treat it with
some of the same compounds that are used
in uh Neuroscience in in humans and in
rats as memory blockers so so things
that block recall or or memory
consolidation and when you do that you
can make the animal forget how many
heads it's supposed to have and then
they basically turn into a featureless
circle when when you can just wipe you
can just wipe the the pattern memory
completely with it using exactly the
same techniques you would use in a in a
rat or a human they just forget what to
do when they turn into they fail to
break Symmetry and they just become a
Circle so yeah I I think I think what
you were saying is is right on with with
this this ability to uh store
counterfactual states that are not true
now but may represent
aspects of the of the future I think
that's that's a very important capacity
another important notion is a constraint
uh constraint satisfaction a constraint
is a rule that tells you uh whether two
things are compatible or not and the
constraint is satisfied if they're
compatible so you basically have a
number of conditions that you establish
by measuring that somehow for instance
uh whether you have a head or multiple
heads and you try to find a solution
where you can end up with exactly one
head and if you end up with exactly one
head based on the starting State then
you have managed to find a way to
satisfy your constraints and so in a
sense uh what you call a competency is
the ability of a system to take a region
of this of states of the space of the
universe some basically some local
region of possible state that the Euros
can be in and move that region to a
smaller region that is acceptable so the
basically there is a region on the
universe State space where you have only
one head
and there's a larger region where you
don't have any head at all but the
starting state of your organism and then
you try to get from A to B so you get
from this larger region to the one in
which you want to be of course if you
have one head you want to stay in the
region in which you have one head which
of course is usually much easier but the
ability basically to condense the space
to get to Bridge Over many regions into
the target region is what comes down to
this this is what this competency is the
system basically has an emergent wanting
to go in this region and it's trying to
move there and so there are constraints
on the level of the substrate
uh that are battling with the functional
constraints that the organism wants to
realize to fulfill its function and
sometimes uh you cannot satisfy this and
you end up with two heads because you
don't know which one you'll get rid of
or how to digest one of the heads and so
on and you end up with some Siamese twin
and uh so this this is an interesting
constraint that you have to solve for
when you are dealing with reality and
how you battle with the substrate until
you get to the functional solution that
you evolve for
yeah it's that's that's interesting I
mean we we've also found that there are
so so we look at exactly this uh the the
navigation this kind of navigation and
Morpher space how you get from here to
there and what paths are possible to get
from here to there and so on one of the
things that we found is that there are
regions of that space that belong to
other species and you can you can push a
a planarian with a standard wild type
genome into the goal state of a
completely different species so we can
get them to grow ahead so there's a
species that normally has a triangular
head you can make it grow a round head
like a like an like a different species
or or a flathead or whatever uh you can
so those are about 100 100 to 150
million years of evolutionary distance
and you can do it you know within within
a few days just by um by by perturbing
that electrical circuit so that it lands
in the wrong space and then outside of
that there are regions that don't belong
to planaria at all so planaria are
normally nice and flat we can make we've
made planarians that are they look like
a they are cylinder like like a ski cap
you know they become like a like a like
a hemisphere or really weird ones that
are spiky they're they're like a ball
with spikes on it they're all kinds of
other uh regions in that space that you
can that you can push them to uh and so
those are new those are not species that
they diverge from those are no one's
ever said to my knowledge that's yes
there's no such there are no such
species
um it's easier to you know and we've
done this in frog too you can you can
push tadpoles to make it to look like
those of other species
um or you can make you know I mean
that's a whole interesting thing for
evolution anyway right what one species
birth defect is a pretty is a perfectly
reasonable different species so we can
make we can make tadpoles with a rounded
tail which for a xenopus tadpole is a
terrible Tale But for zebrafish that's
exactly the right tale so you can sort
of Imagine imagine right Evolution uh
manipulating the different information
processing whether whether by the
bioelectrical circuits or other other
Machinery uh that help the system
explore that morphe space and you know
start to
uh this is start to start to move away
from from whatever the you know that
speciation is moving away from your
standard attractor that you usually land
on how does this relate to intelligence
well intelligence is the ability to make
models and and usually in the service of
control at least that's the way I would
uh explain intelligence
there are other definitions but it's the
simplest one that I found it also
accounts for the fact that many
intelligent people are not very good at
getting things done uh that's it's
basically an intelligence and goal
rationality are support orthogonal
and excessive intelligence is often a
prosthesis for bad regulation have you
read the intelligence trap
no okay the author makes a similar case
and he's coming on shortly essentially
saying that there are certain traps that
people with high IQs have that are not
beneficial for them as biological beings
they're mainly cognitive biases so for
instance it's extremely interesting so
let's just give one of the biases to say
you're either liberal biased or you're
conservative biased and then you were to
give a test where there's some data that
says that on the surface it shows that
the data shows that gun control prevents
gun violence well the Liberals are more
likely to say yes this data does show
that but if you're conservative you're
more likely to find oh actually the
subtleties in the data show that gun
control increases gun violence and then
they thought okay well let's just switch
this to make it such that The
Superficial data suggests that gun
control increases violence you need to
look at the data carefully to show that
it actually prevents violence well the
conservatives in that case would be more
quickly to say oh look the gun control
increases violence and the Liberals
would find the the loophole well that's
one of the reasons why I don't mind
interviewing people who are biased
because to me they're more able to find
a justification for something that that
may be true but I or and others are so
well we all have our own biases we're so
inclined in some other direction that we
just we're blind to it but anyway the
point is to affirm what you're saying
yosha okay so I know Michael has a hard
cut off at 2PM so I want to ask the
question for AGI that is artificial
general intelligence it seems as though
we're far away or that our current
methods of machine learning and what we
learn in Neuroscience or or what we
learn in computer science is something
that we're missing some paradigm shift
or we're missing some new techniques is
there something from Michael's work
Yoshi I'm asking you this and then
Michael please respond is there
something from Michael's work that you
think can be applied to the development
of AGI if such a creature mind can exist
because there are some arguments against
it so first of all I don't know how far
we are for the HEI it could be that the
existing private names are sufficient to
brute force it
but we don't know that yet right so
we're going to find out in the next few
months uh but it could also be that we
need to rewrite the stack to build
systems that work in real time that are
entangled with the environment that can
build uh shared representations with the
environment and uh that we need to
rewrite the stack and there are actually
a number of questions that I'd like to
ask Michael
um what uh I noticed that Michael is
wisely reluctant to use certain words
like Consciousness a lot and it's
because a lot of people are very
opinionated about what these concepts
mean and you first have to deal with
these opinions before you come down to
saying oh here I have the following
proposal for implementing reflexive
attention as a tool to form coherence
and a representation and this leads to
the same phenomena as what you call
consciousness
right so uh that is is a detailed
discussion maybe you don't want to have
that discussion in every Foreman rather
than uh that and then having this
discussion you may be looking at uh how
to create coherence using a reflexive
attention process that makes a real-time
model of what it's attending to and the
fact that it's attending to it so it
remains coherent but for itself so this
is a concrete thing but uh I wonder how
to implement this in a self-organized
fashion if the substrate that you have
are individual agents and there is a
similarity here between societies and
brains and social networks
that is uh if you have
self-interested agents in a way that try
to survive
and that get their rewards from other
agents that are similar to them
structurally
and and they have the capacity to learn
to some degree
and that capacity is sufficient so they
can in the aggregate learn arbitrary
programs arbitrary computable functions
and it's efficient enough so they can
Converge on the functions that they need
to to as a group reap rewards that apply
to the whole group because they have a
shared Destiny like the poor little
cells that are locked in the same skull
and they are all going to die together
if they [ __ ] up so they have to get
along they have to form an organization
that is Distributing rewards among each
other and this gives us a search space
for possible systems that can exist and
the search space is mostly given I think
by the minimal agent that is able to
learn how to distribute rewards
efficiently
while doing something useful using these
rewards to change how you do something
useful so you have an emerging form of
governance in these systems there's not
some centralized control that is imposed
on the system from the outside as an
existing machine learning approaches and
AI approaches but this is this only is
an emergent pattern in the interactions
between the individual small units small
reinforcement learning agents and this
control architecture leads to
hierarchical government it's not fully
decentralized in any way there are
centralized structures that distribute
rewards for instance via the
dopaminergic system and very centralized
top-down Manner and that's because every
regulation has an optimal layer where it
needs to take place some stuff needs to
be decided very high up some stuff needs
to be optimally regulated very low down
depending on the incentives game
theoretically a government is an agent
that imposes an offset on your payoff
metrics to make your Nash equilibrium
compatible with the globally best
outcome
right so to to do this you need to have
agents that are sensitive to rewards
it's super interesting to think about
these reward infrastructures Elon Musk
has bought Twitter I think because he
has realized that Twitter is the network
of among all the social networks that is
closest to a global brain
it's totally mind-blowing to realize
that he basically trades a bunch of
frothy stock for the opportunity to
become Pope pope of a religion that has
more active participants than
Catholicism even right daily
practitioning people who enter this
church and think together and it's a
thing that is completely incoherent at
this point almost and completely
incorrect the bubbles of sentience but
for the most part this thing is just
screeching at itself
and now the SD question can we fix the
incentives of Twitter to turn it into a
global brain
and a Elon Musk is global brain build he
believes that this is the case and
that's the experiment that he is trying
to do which makes me super excited right
this might fail is a very big chance
that it fails but there is also the
chance that we get the global brain that
we get emerging collective intelligence
it is working in real time using the
internet in a way that didn't exist
before so super fascinating thing that
might happen here and it's fascinating
that very few people are seeing this
that Elon Musk is crazy enough to to
spend 44 billion dollars on that
experiment just because he can and has
nothing else to do with things it's
meaningful to do it more meaningful than
having so much money in the bank right
so this makes me interested in this test
bed for rewards and this is something
that translates into the way in which
society is organized because social
media is not different from society not
separate from it problem of governing
social media is exactly the same thing
as governing a society you need a right
form of government you need a legal
system ultimately you need
representation and all these issues
right it's not just the moderation team
and the same thing is also true for the
brain what is the government of the
brain that emerges in what Gary Edelman
calls neural Darwinism among different
forms of organization in the mind until
you have a model of a self-organizing
agent that discovers that what it's
Computing is driving the behavior of an
agent in the real world and discovers a
first person perspective and so on how
does that work how can we get a system
that is looking for the right incentive
architecture and that is basically the
main topic where I I think that where
Michael's research is pointing from from
my perspective that is super interesting
we have this overlap between the looking
at cells and looking at the world and of
humans and animals and stuff in general
yeah yeah so super interesting um we so
so Chris fields and I are are working on
a model of of on a framework to
understand the the
where where
um Collective agents first come from
right oh well how Auto police is how do
they organize themselves and we've we've
we've we've got a model already about
this idea of of rewards and sells
rewarding other cells with with
neurotransmitters and things like this
to keep copies of themselves nearby
because they're the most predictable so
so this idea of reducing surprise well
what's the least surprising thing it's a
copy of yourself and so you can sort of
this with Chris calls it the Imperial
model of multicellularity but one thing
to really think about here is Imagine an
embryo this is a um an amniote embryo
let's say a human or or a bird or
something like that and what you have
there is you have a flat disk of fifty
to ten thousand fifty thousand cells and
when people look at it you say what is
that they say it's an embryo one one
embryo well the reason it's one embryo
is that under normal conditions what's
going to happen is that in this in this
disc one cell is symmetry breaking one
cell is going to decide that it's the
organizer it's going to do local
activation long range inhibition it's
going to tell all the other cells you're
not the organizer I'm the organizer and
as a result you get one special point
that uh begins uh the a process that's
going to walk through this amorphous
space and create a particular
large-scale structure with two eyes and
four legs and whatever else it's going
to have but here's the interesting thing
those cells that's not really one embryo
that's that's um a weird kind of
Freudian ocean of potentiality what I
mean by that is if you take and I did
this as a grad student you can take a
needle and you can put a little scratch
through that blastoderm put a little
scratch through it what will happen is
the cells on either side of that scratch
don't feel each other they don't hear
each other's signals so that symmetry
breaking process will happen twice once
on each end and then when it heals
together what you end up with is two
conjoined twins because because each
side organized an embryo and now you've
got two conjoined twins now many
interesting things happen there uh one
is that every cell is some other cells
in external environment so in order to
make an embryo you have to self-organize
A system that puts an arbitrary boundary
between itself and the outside world you
have to decide where do I end and the
world begins and it's not given to you
uh you know somehow um from outside for
a biological system every biological
system has to figure this out for itself
unlike modern robotics or whatever where
it's very clear here's where you are
here's where the world is these are your
reflectors these are your sensors here's
the boundary of the outside world living
things don't have any of that they have
to figure out all of this out from
scratch the benefit to being able to
figure it out from scratch having to
figure out from scratch is that you are
then compatible with all kinds of weird
initial conditions for example if I
separate you in half you can make two
you can make twins you don't you don't
have a failure you know a total failure
because now you have half the number of
cells you can make twins you can make
triplets but probably you know many more
than that so if you ask the question you
look at that um blasted room and you ask
how many individuals are there you
actually don't know it could be zero it
could be one it could be some small
number of individuals that process of
Auto releases has to happen and and and
here all the here are a number of things
that that are uniquely biological that
that I think relate to the kind of
flexibility plasticity uh that you need
for for for AGI in whatever space it
doesn't have to be the same space that
we work in but your your boundaries are
not set for you by an outside Creator
you have to figure out where your
boundaries are where is the outside
world so you make hypotheses about where
you end and where the world begins you
don't actually know what your structure
is kind of like Bond guards robots from
2006 where they didn't know their
structure and they had to make
hypotheses about well do I have wheels
do I have legs what do I have and then
make a model based on basically babbling
right like the way that babies babble so
so you have to figure out you have to
make a model of of where the boundary is
you have to make a model of what your
structure is you are energy limited
which most the most Ai and Robotics
nowadays are not when your energy and
time limited it means that you cannot
pay attention to everything you are
forced to coarse grain in some way and
lose a lot of information and compress
it down so you have to you have to
choose a lens a coarse graining lens on
the world and figure out how you're
going to represent things
um uh and and all of this has to and and
there are many more things that we could
talk about but all of these things are
self-constructions from the from the
very beginning and and then and then you
have to you have to uh you start to act
in various in various spaces which again
are not predefined for you you have to
solve problems that are metabolic
physiological anatomical maybe
behavioral if you have muscles
um but but nobody's telling nobody's
defining the space for you
um for example if you're a bacterium a
Chris field zupo points this out if
you're a bacterium and you're in some
sort of chemical gradient you want to
increase the amount of sugar in your
environment you could act in
three-dimensional Space by physically
swimming up the gradient or you can act
in transcriptional Space by turning on
other genes that are better at
converting whatever sugar happens to be
around and that solves your your
metabolic problem instead of right so
you have these hybrid problem spaces so
all of this I think what what
contributes in a strong sense to all the
things that that we were just talking
about is the fact that everything is in
in biology is self-constructed from the
beginning you can't rely on you don't
know ahead of time when you're a new
creature Born Into the world and we have
many I have many examples of of this
kind of stuff you don't know how many
cells you have how big your cells are
you can't count on any of the priors so
you have this like weird thing that
Evolution makes these these machines
that don't take the past history too
seriously it doesn't over train on them
it makes problem-solving machines that
use whatever Hardware you have this is
why we can make weird chimeras and and
and cyborgs and and you can mix things
and mix and match the biology in every
in every way with other living things or
with with non-living things because all
of this is interoperable because it does
not make assumptions about what you have
to have it tries to solve whatever
problem it's given it plays the hands
that it's dealt and um that that that
results in uh that assumption that you
cannot uh you cannot trust what you come
into the world with you cannot assume
that the hardware is what it is it gives
rise to a lot of that intelligence I
think and a lot of that plasticity so if
you translate this into necessary
insufficient conditions what seems to be
necessary for the emergence of general
intelligence in bunch of cells or units
is that basically each of them is a
small agent which means it's able to
behave with an expectation of minimizing
future Target value deviations so it
learns that the configurations
environment that signal anticipated
reward next thing these units need to be
not just agents that need to be
connected to each other
and they need to get their Rewards or
proxy rewards something that allows them
to anticipate whether the organism is
going to feed them in the future from
other units that also adaptive
so you need multiple message types and
the ability to recognize and send them
with a certain degree of reliability
uh what else do you need you need enough
of them of course
what what's not clear to me is how
deterministic do the units need to be
how much memory do they need to be or
which way how much State can they store
how much uh
how deep in time does the indeed
recollection need to go and how much
forward in time do they need to be able
to form expectations so basically how
large is this activation front that they
can or this or the shape of the
distribution that they can learn
and have to learn to make this whole
thing happen
and so basically the conditions that are
necessary are relatively simple
if you just wait for long enough and get
a search assistance to percolate I
imagine that the compound agency will at
some level emerge on the system just in
the competition of
um possibilities in the same way as
emerging agency has emerged on Twitter
in a way with
um devoke religion in a way that people
who are starting to shift around their
behavior to maximize likes and retweets
and there was no external reward that
was given on Twitter so as a result a
local structure emerged a local agency
that was Shifting the rewards by itself
an emerging causal structure that was in
some sense in Dawn what causation
going to organize groups of people into
a behavioral things it's really
interesting to look at better as
something like a mind at some level
right it's working slower but it would
probably be possible to make a
simulation of these Dynamics in a more
abstract way and to use this for
arbitrary problem solving
and so what would an experiment look
like in which we start with these
necessary conditions and narrow down the
sufficient conditions yeah
yeah yeah very very right on and that's
I mean yeah we're doing some of that
stuff uh some of that kind of modeling I
apologize I've got a I've got a um I've
gotta run here thank you both for coming
out for this I appreciate it thank you
so much and thank you for bringing us
together so a great great conversation I
really enjoyed it so yeah thank you
anyways I've enjoyed it very much thank
you thank you thank you so much thanks
Russia the podcast is now concluded
thank you for watching if you haven't
subscribed or clicked on that like
button now would be a great time to do
so as each subscribe and like helps
YouTube push this content to more people
also I recently found out that external
links count plenty toward the algorithm
which means that when you share on
Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on top full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you